okay so I'm going to talk about them
wash I long title about them phase
transitions and approximating to spin
systems in hyper graph some the most
important in here it's a joint work with
andreas longus and the other thing is
I'm going to try to start quite slowly a
lot of you heard get almonds excellent
survey and food camp and a lot of you
know more about it than I do so you'll
find the beginning very slow but it's
actually for everybody else and so
please interrupt at any point if you
have any questions okay so I'm going to
start by talking about phase transitions
and approximation in to spin systems and
this is a little along the lines of what
you tom was talking about okay so in
this talk we're gonna have the two spins
0 and 1 and the spins interact and at
the beginning I'm going to just have a
simple interaction matrix a and the
meaning of this matrix is if you have
spin zero next to spin zero that gives
you an interaction with weight buta
it'll become more clear what that means
zero vs 1 this gives you a 1 1 vs. 1
gives you eight gamma so these are some
parameters and there's another parameter
lambda which is sometimes called an
external field in this case it's going
to be a weight that arises from having a
spin zero all right so the whole thing
lives on a graph G so we've got some
vertices V and we've got some edges of
the graph and what we're interested in
is configurations and
and what a configuration is is it just
assigned spins to the vertices okay so
some vertices get spin through summer
juses that's been one but a
configuration has a weight and this is
important so just like the number of
symbols it's important to take in what
this way it is so what is the way what
frankly edge of the graph we get an
interaction between the spins at its end
points according to this matrix so 0
next 20 that gives me a factor of theta
one next one that gives me 2 gamma
anything else gives me a 10 also every
vertex that gets been zero that gives me
a factor of lambda okay so that's the
weight of the configuration what's the
partition function it's just the sum of
all those ways okay I want to pause cuz
the whole 45 minutes will be a great big
yawn if you didn't get that yeah is that
good okay sorry so that's what the
that's what is the object of study and
we're interested in studying how you can
compute this partition function and
normally you can't so we're interested
in how you can approximate the partition
function alright so let's go for some
common examples so if i should beta
equal 0 and gamma equals 1 this is
either Paul the Civil hardcore model um
the important thing about it is that
configurations are independent sets why
because beta 0 so if I have spin zero
next to spin zero that compaq moves away
0 anything else wait 1 so configurations
are exactly independent sets and they're
they're weighted according to how many
vertices are in all right sorry
okay so let's just do a time you little
example so here's my graph uvw a little
triangle I've taken the hardcore so what
kind of configurations might I have well
I might have a configuration with all
one's what's the way to that
configuration wait 1 way 1 way 1 so its
way one I might have a configuration
with a single 0 there i get a lander for
the 0 but all interactions have weight
one there's three configurations that
look like that am I the configuration
with two zeros but that has 10 but
they're 000 that's PETA so only 30 said
the partition function is 1 plus 3
lambda that's what we're trying to
compute okay now we can you say
something by way of motivation of this
mode of motivation so sure so then i'll
second i briefed by my affection so why
are you interested in computing this
partition function well the reason is
that actually lots of them qualitative
things depend on it so the first is that
this is the normalizing factor in the
so-called gibbs distribution which is
what will get to and so if you wanted to
compute the probability of some
configuration this would be the
normalization but more important to love
this that's what's actually really
important to the physicist and that's
the so-called free energy of the system
that's probably as much as that yeah
okay so that's that um now you'll notice
it in the example that I gave beta times
gamma is less than 1 well this is either
0 that's the so-called anti
ferromagnetic regime you can think about
it in terms of the determinant of the
little matrix kind of mean spins sort of
prefer to be different rather than being
the same and we'll stop doing examples
but another important examples the case
would be
Eagles amo which is the easing model and
again you didn't have a less than one is
once I'm to Carolina got it okay so
that's that's the setup and to avoid
trivialities I'm going to assume always
that gammas bigger than 0 otherwise that
I would just without loss of generality
I'd have the matrix 0 1 1 0 which just
forces adjacent spins to be different
which is to coloring so that that's not
very interesting so we're just going to
assume from now on that gammas bigger
than 0 now we want to know about how
difficult it is to approximate that this
partition function that's that the goal
and in order to study the difficulty of
that approximation it turns out to be
useful to study random configurations in
fact your question was really helpful
because actually even to make sense of
this what I now need to do is talk a
little bit about putting a probability
distribution on configurations and the
relevant probability distribution is
exactly the one given by these weights
okay so so if you have a finite graph G
like what we've got the important thing
is the line at the top at the moment so
the game is labor it's just the measure
on configurations it's maps and spins
two vertices which waits a configuration
with probability proportional to its
weight so it's just what what the what
we've been doing yeah so sorry ilysm so
yeah so like the weight of this
configuration is lambda over 1 plus 3
lambda that sort of thing all right
that's what's going on now those of you
have been here a little while or who've
already know about this stuff know good
and well that it makes perfect sense to
define me Gibbs measure not just on a
finite graph but also on an infinite
graph and also for those of you that
don't know this turns out to be a really
useful thing to do even if we're
interested in finite grams okay so um so
okay so a Gibson measure on infinite
graph what is it I'm not going to be
very formal business like it a nun
rigorous definition but um what is it
it's it it's a measure on configurations
on the infinite graph which has the
property that if you look at a little a
little so we've got some into the draft
if you're looking into the tree that's
the most relevant one and if you look at
a little fine art piece suppose you
assemble a configuration from the
infinite measure and then you just fix
the configuration around the boundary
what does that induce something you're
fine art piece exactly the Gibbs measure
condition on the boundary okay so that's
that's what what gives Majora's on into
the graph and the important thing turns
out to be that there might be just one
of those or there could be many of them
okay all right now this is all all kind
of them history but for those of you
don't know it there's there's a really
neat thing that turns out to be true so
I'm going to spend alone a relatively
long time because if you don't take any
if you don't know this this is the most
important thing in the talk and that
that says so suppose we have an anti
ferromagnetic to spin system so that's
one where spins prefer to be different
beta gamma less than 1 i'm suppose
suppose I fix any Delta so that's going
to be a good rebound let's not make it
too because that sort of trivial but
anything that's at least three
and here's really amazing fact and this
has been developed by lots of people
maybe I can pick out the bits for you in
a second but um but rather first I want
to concentrate on the UM the important
um fat and the fact is that suppose you
want to know I've got the partition
function oh no can I approximate it on
graphs of degree at most Delta okay so
that's a question for arbitrary fixed
graphs the inputs any old fixed browser
degree in most Delta you want to know
can I approximate the partition function
well this connects exactly to where the
question of whether if I take an
infinite Delta regular tree is there
just one Gibbs measure or are there more
than one okay so let's um so let's pick
this out so so we look at the infinite
Delta regular tree all right check them
on the drug because I've got it a
picture here for delta equals four what
this is is that if they are kind of
Delta regulatory suppose it has multiple
Gibbs measures so there's more than one
measure that we can put on this such
that it can take a little region it does
with the observatory's that's an
undirected tree it is yes well it's got
a rude so you here yeah most of the
vertices have got degree 5 okay
expertise I was trying to sweep that
into the cockpit others in a very
temporary that's funny so finish i faded
the Delta regular tree so um except for
it but yeah it isn't I mean they're ok
so my has a steamy what about the root
shed does it have degree one less and
shouldn't I really have given it an
extra child and the answer is for what
I'm going to say this makes you leave
the tiniest technical difference and I
don't really even want to go there but
it's a good question yeah m what does m
civil defense uh okay excellent sorry um
going so slowly I'll get there in one
second but it's a good good okay
excellent okay so we've got this Delta
regular tree i miss my point on I've
kind of didn't dry Delta regular Delta
Delta branching and either one don't
worry about it um okay suppose that has
multiple Gibbs measures okay so you look
at the tree it either does have multiple
Gibbs measures or it doesn't suppose it
does so there's a fixie see it depends
on the parameters beta gamma delta such
that it's beyond be hard to approximate
the partition function now here's n of
an end vertex graph g within a factor of
C to the young so you can't even get
with the in an exponential factor even
if you strict your inputs to a delta
regular rap okay so multiple measures
means really hot on degree delta graphs
even if i take delta regular graphs I
cannot approximate will say more about
it what about the other direction the
other direction suppose that for aldi
thurs the most don't done but this tree
actually just has one Gibbs measure then
there's actually an approximation scheme
a fully polynomial time approximation
scheme on arbitrary graphs of degree
Delta so this is saying if you want to
know how hard it is to approximate on
bounded degree graphs even though your
graphs are fine I've even though they're
arbitrary will you have no idea what
they look like all you really need to
care about is this very nice Delta
regular tree how do you check with it
it's got one measure or more and that
will tell you the answer and I really
should okay so that the color is to give
you an idea about which groups were
involved to which part of the word came
I get okay is that so that's that's
really interesting and that's kind of
you know this is ever
thing about you antiferromagnetic to
spin system so no going to be really
understand everything all right now um
because of this fat obviously you'd love
to know when is the trillion uniqueness
right if you're given parameters beta
gamma lambda you want to know whether
it's some uniqueness or not so you know
that you can approximate or not and
fortunately ah this is remind me
goodnight there's a little thing at the
boundary that may not be understood and
I don't want to talk about it okay so
we're not going to look right at the
boundaries ok ok so what we really would
like to understand is when our beta and
gamma and lambda in the unity this
region right because if they're in
uniqueness approximation is easy if
they're not in uniqueness it's hot so
let's try to understand when they're at
uniqueness and I can't draw
three-dimensional pictures in any way
Mike might recognize I still pissed
picture from something else from very
long ago but anyway where do I look at
lambda equals one so let's let you in to
draw the pictures I'm going to forget
about the field and I'm going to look at
a plot where I've got betta along the
horizontal axis and gamma along the
vertical axis and then I'm going to tell
you something about what's true about
uniqueness and the first observation
that's known is that if you look in that
little square bounded by betta at most 1
and gamma at most one then if you let
don't take it big enough you're
definitely in non-uniqueness ok so
within this little square approximation
is hard because if Delta gets big enough
you're in not even is so as long as the
degree bounders big enough approximation
is hard on the other hand oh and this
hyperbola here is betta gamma equals 1
so that's ferromagnetic above that and
um as you can rocks me there by John
since I
well yeah in the symmetric case but um I
want to talk about the region in here
and add in here between this way to
another the hyperbola it's always the
case that um if you make built a big
enough you're in uniqueness okay so that
said you might think I'm great
approximation is easy because I'm a
uniqueness but remember the requirement
for approximation is it for all d
greater than Delta you're ready
uniqueness either ah he said the greater
than Delta with you they die okay I
didn't mean to thank you okay alright so
the requirement is for all do less than
or equal to Delta um you have to be in
uniqueness for it to be easy and what
this says is that it Delta gets big
enough here in uniqueness um there's not
a nice closed form for individual Delta
that the curve looks something not not
very much like this curve but something
like that nevertheless it's actually
easy to tell whether a given set of
parameters is in uniqueness and I
thought what I would do is just show you
how would you do it suppose somebody
handed parameters and you wanted to know
how my anus and because I ought to
eventually get on to our step I'm not
going to prove this to you but it's
actually not very hard but i'm going to
show you ok so how I've ever a system
characterized by be there gamma lambda
delta and i want to know is it some
uniqueness and the truth is all you have
to do to tell whether it's am uniqueness
let's look at this little function f ok
and uniqueness hold on the delta a
regular tree if when you apply this
function twice there is a unique
positive fixed point ok now it's easy to
derive this function
but what I'm going to do instead is I'm
going to let you pattern match so
remember that our matrix would be tough
one so look at the numerator you see
betta in one and then remember it's one
gamma and if you look at the denominator
you see one gamma so somehow maybe this
F isn't very surprising given the matrix
okay so how would you tell whether when
you apply F twice it has a unique
positive fixed point well I decided to
just show you it done in Mathematica
okay so what I've done here is I've
written two little recurrences based on
that function f so the first one says y
equals lambda term speed X with Y over X
plus gamma to the Delta minus 1 what's
the second would say same thing that
it's X in terms of Y ok so i just wrote
through two variables because you got to
fly it twice ok then what i asked them
if matt couldn't do this merit
numerically and i just gave it the
hardcore parameters theta zero gamma 1
lambda 1 and let's just try it for delta
equals 3 4 5 6 so for delta equals 3
mathematica find one fixed point indeed
it's in uniqueness delta equals for its
and uniqueness of funds one don't equals
five of the seed wanna do this
rigorously but this is to just show you
tell the equal 6 it's actually not a
uniqueness matemática solving how does
it solve a woman in America if it's a
numerical solution then it's only an
approximate fixed right that's right in
fact you gonna do it rigorously and you
can't do a rigorous so if it's you don't
know if you know if it's almost a fixed
point that's right and in fact you to
look at the derivative and when you do
it in real life you better be rigorous
and
is to do that yeah and I don't yeah I
probably want to go there too much soul
I've done in this top you showed your
numerical but I I haven't cheated so
that the things that i showed you
numerical do correspond to the bigger
sleep injuries but i'm only showing the
miracle to just give you an idea but
you're absolutely right you have to do
it properly imposing these almost a fix
point it doesn't does it tell you
anything now now you really have to
check but you can't check right anybody
I ok so the pink one there it's time he
shows a single bit yeah I know and
that's that's very much about the end
and really ok so what mike is saying oh
no fifth there is only one the last one
and the last one of course there's a
symmetrical thing we did funds on the
left that's not fixed there you go okay
I'm worried different yes they are
different I all about it's like that and
that is an excellent so there are
different and they're different on
purpose and the reason it looks confused
probably as a bad idea for me to but in
America I was just trying to show you
without getting bogged down Nick
mathematical ought to found a solution
symmetric to that and if there are to be
three here and either I truncated it
because it didn't fit or it did it but
I'm about to tell you that and it's a
great point that worked out I think that
was my point I mean if you say so eggs
nice hot cup of things or not yeah miss
Lydia and let me say one more thing
about it answer why are not going to be
the same okay they would be the segment
that's the whole point okay and that's
why it's f composed with it oh that's
just the result of solving it once exam
I see I'm set oh sorry maybe what I
should have said it to explain it better
is that it's obvious then you're always
going to get one solution where x and y
are the same because look at the
equation i make x and y the same and
just find a fixed point in the equation
again however there might be a solution
where x and y are different if there is
there will be a symmetric matching
solution which would
that was showing here that my book not
raised so many alarm bells for you and
the question of our uniqueness is
actually that whether there's just the
solution where x and y are the same or
is there another solution where they're
different thank you okay no I just want
to love it so two more little question
one is you you say that you can you can
analyze that analytically you can it can
actually show some conditions where you
could verify it it has a unique fixed
point for a given Delta yeah but is
there any monotonicity invent no there's
not yeah um well there's a there's so
many kisses your condition you need to
know and so that's a big pink okay yeah
okay um is this for all beta all all
beta gamma in the anti paramedic
government whether they're in the square
or not um yes yes and this is important
because in the square you know that if
Delta gets being then you're hard but
outside the square you know eventually
for being Delta that those ones are any
maintenance but there might be some
smaller Delta that's not any uniqueness
smaller D and that's you would have to
know for all okay and just as I thought
it might be good to kind of give you a
little idea what this means and okay so
let's suppose that Delta was three so
we're looking at independent set on the
free regulatory
looking at this solution I just want to
tell you how does this solution to this
equation correspond to what a typical
configuration looks like what is the
goods measure and actually the gifts
measure is the one where notes are spin
zero in the infinite set with
probability x over 1 plus X which is
there not for 32 so in a typical
infinite set on for the three regulatory
all the nodes are in the independent set
with probability about a third whereas
if you get up to degree 6 and this is
dumb what Eric was saying in response to
my question what happens is if you look
at the solution where X is about not
point 06 and why is about not point 7
you get alternating layers so nodes are
in on one level with probability those
are not down translates to himself about
nothing or six and on alternate levels
about not point for two okay so that's
what happens and that's the
non-uniqueness is that the parody of the
tree comes into it and on even levels
say no to call unlikely to be in pod
levels just under half and of course
there's a symmetric solution the other
way okay now that is an other way I
explained it numerically due to lack of
time etc that's a kind of completely
beautiful situation because the truth is
entirely used it okay so it's the
infantry and this phase transition
exactly tells you whether it's hard or
easy so this is this is the really nice
world um know what I'm next going to
tell you is that sadly that when you
increase the arity of constraints life
gets not less nice I mean not just that
we can't prove as much but the truth is
much more ugly um so that's what I'm
going to tell you about it and so I
won't go back to our set up so this is
exactly what you've seen before and
let's just think about area Madhuri
the set up so that instead of being
constraints on edges zero reacts with
spin zero on this edge with beata etc
what if we have caring interaction so a
set of vertices interacts ok so let's do
that so instead of having an interaction
matrix which is essentially a arity to
function we're going to look at having a
symmetric air DK function so spins on K
vertices interact what they're going to
do it on a symmetric way so it just
depends how many zeros and how many
wants in that cake oh no means instead
of having a graph we ought to have a
hypergraph all right so we'll have a que
uniform hyper graph where I'm it stores
maximum degree Doctor which means these
vertex is if it was guilt the hyper
edges okay and everything else is as you
expect the weight of a configuration
I've seemed to blast the feel though I
think because we don't have a field in
this picture I figured it out so the
weight of a configuration is that just
the product over then hyper edges of the
weight of the interaction the hyper
edges and what's the partition function
it's the sum of these weights so we're
looking at lambda equal one but we
generalized everything to the hypergraph
case okay our interactions okay and it
turns out that we know so little about k
equals one that in this talk and even in
life there's not too much we know and so
I'm going to restrict to the case where
these functions are essentially
relations so okay so obviously it makes
sense to have these functions to
arbitrary real numbers but I'm not going
to do that in the remainder of the talk
okay all right now it turns out the life
life gets much more ugly because I might
not be so what we used to have was this
nice computational threshold and bounded
degree graphs up to some Delta those are
easy and after that hard but it turns
out that in the high air d case this
might not even exist and if it does it
might not coincide with a uniqueness
threshold and so on before i get to what
we've done i want to just start by
giving you some examples and the first
example are going to look at is what's
called strong independent sets in a
hypergraph so strong independent sets is
the constraint that says the
configuration is good if for every
hyperedge you really only have 10 at
most 10 so i've drawn here three hyper
edges those are my they're all air d3
subjective cables 30 join you three
hyper edges liebe too many fries but
this is a good configuration because if
you look at any hyperedge i have at most
10 right this guy has exactly one this
guy has them so here's another decent
configuration at most one is there okay
so that's that's the constraint I want
to talk about and what so if I want to
go if I want to talk about the
uniqueness special the next thing I need
to do is I need to generalize this
infinite tree that we've been looking at
into an infinite hyper tree to find out
what's the right thing to be looking at
and easiest way to draw yeah look at
that they are the infinite hyper tree is
a kind of two step thing so I that I've
Illustrated this with cake and three and
delta equals fine so I've got on every
every hyperedge consistent
paper read Jeff one which has three
vertices in it w11 w 1 2 and 3 and I've
drawn the tree in layers so that
vertices so the meaning of this is that
this vertex V Delta's five so he's
actually in five Piper edges f + f1 f2
f3 f4 this is a hyper edge so he's not
three vertices and in the infinite tree
everything is new there's no cycles so
that just goes ok so you can you can
analyze this hyper tree just like the
tree and I've done it again with
Mathematica and what's true about it for
hardcore is that also stuffing again
here's the occurrences and you can see
that the era d comes in and I'm not
going to drive that for you but it's not
about to show and I look for some
solutions for the independent set and I
applied them for delta equals three and
delta equals four and what mad at
Mathematica finds is actually the truth
here which is in fact its own your new
name is for Delta at verse 3 ok so this
for this um so for these hypergraphs
their only ingredients when the window
is at most three um and yet what's known
actually about partners of approximation
is a little bit on it's a little bit ok
I'll just tell you listen ok now there's
a case so what happens so for Delta at
most three this hyper you're in
uniqueness on this infant hyper tree and
in fact what I'm many people in this
room have shown is that actually you
have what's called strong spatial mixing
and seem to get slower with age so I'm
not gonna have a link to strong spatial
mixing but I think I'll just did
quickly here in our own case i'm not
going to define it but essentially in
fact i'm going to just tell you what it
doesn't explicitly on the trade so
strong spatial mixing says that if i
have the infinite tree or any infinite
rap but anyway I let's say that we look
at um let's say we look at some some
boundary can do so I'm going to or
interested in something actually what
we're interested in the road but whether
it's spin zero or spin one doesn't have
to be the root and now we may have some
boundary conditions are two different
boundary conditions and I'm going to
draw them the way we actually use them
this isn't important so I might have
some boundary information which I a cut
tree with a boundary and I might have
some other one which agrees that random
round'em you know they're around
boundaries a year but they all agree but
then it may disagree down here and
strong spatial 19 says that then the
spin on the thing that I've identified
which is in this case the road it the
American it depends on the two
boundaries decay decays exponentially
not with the distance to the boundary
but with the distance to where the value
differs okay am I because we're short on
time I've drawn it subject suggestively
in this trillions we're going to be
interested in having a boundary dinner
still talking
the same inside ok MXC I don't know
whether if you didn't get that it's
probably not very important but the
thing to take home is that when don't
when you're in uniqueness on this tree
these guys happen to show that strong
special mixing occurs and when strong
special mixing occurs typically through
methods which are go back to door lights
that typically gives us an approximation
scheme and the way you should think
about this at a very very high level is
that if you wanted to approximate the
probability that again a node was in the
independent said because because because
it depends on the boundary in a way that
decays exponentially even if you think
vertices than the tree provides his
method enables you to do that okay um
what I've dealt is four or five well
you're not in uniqueness so you
certainly don't have to come special
mixing so the uniqueness special dis
here very happen in strong specially
tuned so you're good there you're not
even in uniqueness but unlike the
beautiful case that we've looked at with
graphs we don't know whether you're
intractable as soon as you leave
uniqueness and the first place
intractability is known as delta equal
six and this is a this is a little
disappointing because this is the graph
threshold so obviously it's impactful
from there but anyway four and five are
still open and you and Joe have this
interesting argument which I don't have
time to tell you very much about which
shows that um actually natural gadgets
can't be used to show that partners for
these and so we don't know whether it's
hard or not but essentially what goes
wrong on the tree that puts it out of
uniqueness can't easily be turned into
translation invariant hypergraphs and so
although the train is not unique is we
don't know how
to make that give hardness okay um so
kind of here's what we think should
happen for typical functions so
typically and then press ought to exist
up to the store the threshold where you
have strong spatial mixing but in
general that's below that you need a
special um I can click the click the
link to give you an example where it's
below but actually ondrea's is giving a
talk tomorrow where he'll show you an
example where the strong spatial mixing
threshold could actually just be below
do you need this threshold um above the
union is special approximation may be
hard maybe sometimes is proved okay um
so it's not really clear yet we don't
know rigorously whether there's such a
thing as a computational threshold and
if there is we don't know whether it
coincides with the uniqueness special so
unfortunately what i'm going to offer
you is less than I mean what we want
would be an answer to these questions um
what I offer is less than that okay so
this is what we know um so what we know
is that essentially if you take any
non-trivial function f symmetric
function then there is a degree at which
approximation becomes hard okay but we
don't know whether it's the is certainly
certainly but we've proved is not the
adidas turtle them out we don't know
okay so let me talk you through a little
bit hope no so remember the setup rub
you've got the parameters but we were on
hypergraphs I'm so f is just a symmetric
Harry function that's playing the role
of betta and Jana and wanna start out by
looking at which functions ought to
obviously be easy okay so if I have a
function that always says zero well I
can obviously part it approximate the
partition function in zero if the
constraints that i put the hyper edges
are just concerned all obviously to be
one similar um
this constraint says this is the
interaction that just as all the
students have today so obviously if you
have that you can calculate the
partition function reverence applied
those bins have to be zero everybody
else is 3 i'll stay with l1 this is a
constraint that says every vertex in
this hyper and the spins the spins have
to all be the same and you can calculate
the partition function such a system
because you could just collapse all
those vertices into one vertex so the
most even interesting or actually the
last two uh so this constraint Harry
says if you put this on a hyper edge
then all the all the spins they have to
add up to 0 mod 2 so they have 10 they
you know you're allowing a hyper edge
like that because I add up to 0 not to
but you're not alone that ok and I'm act
easy because you can do Gaussian
elimination and you can get that
partition function exactly so all these
guys are trivial so what the theorem
says is that if you take any other room
symmetric boolean function f then there
exists in to green threshold such that
if you're given a que uniform hyper
graph with n vertices then degree most
Delta approximation is actually caught
ok so that's what we know so we do know
that for all the non trivial systems it
is actually hard to get within an
exponential factor for bounded degree
but the big open question is what's the
right answer for the degree
we just proved services yeah okay that's
good so an actual person I so maybe you
considered life with I progress is often
less of you if you assume they're in
linear or simple so the cool degree is
one ok so does freshman at most one okay
so the question is what about putting
constraints on the hypergraph like maybe
you code to bring one and things like
that and we haven't looked at many
constraints and that's what well we have
actually looked a little bit but not
with any interesting results so not with
that particular one but yes there may be
interesting things to do about
constrained hypergraphs and that's
that's interesting what to do I'm
something else I want to mention and
I've only got five minutes but I wanted
just touch briefly on the connection to
constraint satisfaction because in
constrict so far this looks a whole lot
like constraint satisfaction and so I
just want to briefly set that up tell
you what's known there and then show you
kind of what some what's different about
the results in that setting in here ok
so constraints I videos by better first
ok ok so constraint satisfaction um you
typically one has a set of billion
functions it's a constraint language and
again anyone who's in the boot camp
probably saw this a bit but anyway um so
I got a bunch of boolean functions
what's a constraint well just a set of
variables and each constraint applies a
function two variables that's looking a
lot like a hypergraph um the partition
function count satisfying assignments a
lot like a hypergraph so the only um the
only difference really is whether you're
allowed to put parallel hyper edges on
and whether they're allowed to have them
constraint like end
why we're using variables okay so
obviously we got a corollary that the
hydrograph problem is hard for bounded
degree that's kind of for free that's
not very interesting um but what I want
to talk about is that I'm the CSP people
often and I same thing as if it's a wee
everybody in cfb is our free grant to
study what's the so what's so-called
conservative case so I'm going to tell
you what that means and then I'm going
to show you very briefly why that's kind
of a lot different to what's going on in
these thin systems and then I'm gonna
shut up okay so um so what's right about
bounded degree boolean CSP well the
first tract is that if you wanted to
solve the CSP counting problem exactly
then even if you restricted the degree
bound all the way down to three it just
makes no difference okay and it's the
way to see that is that we have to noon
to cut Academy theorems one for the
general case and ones with the bounded
degree case and the truth is just the
same so if the constraints are a fine
that's right to even rub and do exactly
and otherwise even if you restrict three
it's hard to solve exactly now weirdly
the decision problem of a lot list is no
easiest even counting this is kind of a
weird world where in some sense
decisions actually harder to but I mean
it's house counting is hard right so we
know more about it but um research of
the degree also leaves the complexity
unchanged for the decision question but
what everybody who ever studies it does
is that they assume do the instances
that you have what they call these
opinion functions this is the
conservative case which means you're
allowed to go alone round in the input
and say yet but this vertex has to have
sinned
zero yep this vertex has to have spit
lot and really nothing is known if you
get rid of that restriction and what I
say I say I think if you asked about
approximate counting everything is known
about about the boot the CSP if you do
have these two pinning functions and I
want to run out our own paper but I want
to explain how it's different so let me
just sort of explain very briefly what
happens I suppose you have a constraint
so this is X the vector of inputs and
then the value of the function you can't
have everything in so that's a
hypergraph constraint now suppose that I
wanted to say what's the complexity of
approximating the partition function
when I've got this constraint around
well if I were allowed to use Delta 1
which pins the vertex 2 1 then I would
just apply it to pin this vertex 2 1 a
lot about hair is just classical
independent set and independent set is
hard for degree delta equal 6 so okay
that doesn't explain how do you always
find such a thing which was the work in
this paper showing it for any constraint
you can find such a thing but it
explains why the answer is no Table six
everything's hard because it turns out
for any constraint you can always faff
around with the pinning and you can
eventually produce an independent set
now without these pinnings the truth is
different because we already know that
there's a Markov chain for we
sighs which is not what I do over there
but anyway which is the constraint where
at least one of them has to be oh it's
just I flipped it anyway so this is the
constraint where you have to have at
least one one and here it's actually
already known that for any delta as long
as you make the air d big enough there's
a mark of chain so the truth is not
something nice like Delta equal six
rather it depends on the constraint ok
so I am out of time so so this is what
we know and the interesting question is
are really to improve Delta
question this rear its ugly head it does
but not here so this so that this rears
its ugly head in some of these multiple
arity theorem I can get you the one on
dreis no not that one well we know
somewhere it does however in this case
it doesn't so here there's just it's
easy or its MP honey so these are also
at equivalent and there is notice yeah
but there are places where there is this
but sadly i look forward to maybe else
so is it uniqueness of a special mixing
that the end is the important part of
you who don't know yet it could be the
uniqueness he just a red herring right
it's not a participation well it's
interesting for other reasons right
because it tends to say quality of
things but what may be true here it's
sort of saying that this beautiful union
is on the tree that that corresponds to
what you can compute if you're working
on the graph and if you're working about
a new grass but it just probably doesn't
correspond to what you can compute if
you're working on these higher-order
constraints of something different is
good hey yeah so for we have been hard
comma there are cases where like all the
grades its unique as well we have
officer and here it says like we have 0
1 so no weeds is always hard when
doubting is sufficient enough so what do
you think I if we have weight in the
higher the case do you expect like a
sort of track law case for or tails okay
so so he is making the Paris right it's
a one-point hang is making is that gosh
I mentioned one I've been problem which
is what about Delta but i forgot to
mention another a big problem you know
why are you why are you actually just
going to 0 1 come on we had to beat it
again let's put some numbers in there
and what would be the truth if we had
more
and I don't really know oh yeah I mean
it's actually quite difficult with
numbers in here and we have like we
don't know we're working on that but we
don't have a result yeah I think I
should know the answer but I don't
remember if you take graphs of bounty
three weeks you always get ya some
aggressive I'm sorry yes I questions
about bound to treatment and things
become by easy unbounded treatment I'm
not I'm not easy but Cohen in real time
yeah we do it okay why don't we thank
the speaker and take